la légalisation de la marijuana figure
parmi l'un des enjeux de la présente
campagne électorale
notre boussole électorale justement
indique d'ailleurs que 56% de ces
utilisateurs sont en faveur de la
légalisation du cannabis à des fins
récréatives on en parlait hier et bien
l'uruguay a été le premier pays du monde
à légaliser la production la
distribution et la consommation de la
mari dans le but de contrôler le marché
et ainsi le soustraire au crime organisé
jean michel leprince est allé voir
comment ça se passe
valet
voilà
et la magie
un doux samedi soir d'hiver dans un parc
de montevideo ses deux amis d'enfance
s'apprête à poser un geste qui dans de
nombreux pays leur vaudrait des angles
pourtant ils ne pensent qu'à se détendre
un peu ici en uruguay fumer c'est légal
depuis 40 ans mais acheter ou vendre du
cannabis pouvait vous envoyer en prison
mais maintenant les uruguayens peuvent
faire pousser jusqu'à six plants de
cannabis par foyer ou en acheter jusqu'à
40 grammes par mois et par personne
dans un club ou une formation sous la
supervision du gouvernement
c'est le seul pays au monde qui
contrôlent la production la distribution
et la consommation de la marijuana
le père de cette révolution c'est pépé
mujica qui vient de quitter la
présidence de l'uruguay on la surnommait
le président le plus pauvre du monde car
il vivait dans sa modeste demeure
conduisait lui-même sa vieille
coccinelles et donnait plus de 80% de
son salaire à une oeuvre de logements
pour les pauvres
cet ancien guérillero qui a fait 14 ans
de prison sous la dictature a légalisé
l'avortement le mariage gay est le
cannabis
à partir de cette simple constatation 4
pressent un détenu sur 3 1 sur 3 est en
prison à cause de la drogue pour traffic
pour vol pour de l'argent sorry
l'opprimé la brique qu'annoncé monteil
d'abord ne reconnaissons qui vient
marché de la drogue
qu'on le veuille ou non est aujourd'hui
de ce marché est entre les mains des
narcotrafiquants
ce qui est bien pire pour nous que la
marijuana elle même mais je ne veux pas
dire notre choix ballot
l'uruguay petit pays ouvert et
démocratique a souffert comme d'autres
régions d'amérique latine des ravages du
narcotrafic violence corruption
blanchiment d'argent fallait détourné
l'argent du marché noir évalué à 30
millions de dollars par an et le ré
investir en prévention comme on la
politique répressive comme la répression
n'a pas donné de résultat nous devons
avoir une politique beaucoup plus
intelligente et il ne s'agit pas
d'encourager la consommation mais
d'encadrer une consommation légale est
de savoir que lorsqu'elle est exagéré il
s'agit de quelqu'un qui a besoin d'être
il y aurait 200 mille consommateurs
réguliers de cannabis et 20000
consommateurs problématiques dans ce
pays de trois millions trois cent mille
habitants des proportions comparables à
celles du canada lajunta des drogues as
la commission des drogues relève de la
présidence et elle doit veiller à
l'application de la loi qui est avant
tout une expérience ville où il est
nécessaire d' essayer d'autres choses
d'autres modèles les soumettre à des
débats les évaluer pour voir s'ils sont
plus efficaces tout en respectant les
critères du droit et de la santé qui
doivent être nos objectifs ultimes
que ce soit pour usage individuel ou
dans les clubs de cannabis comme celui
ci l'état veut contrôler non seulement
la quantité mais la qualité du produit
il doit remplacer le pote illégal
importé du paraguay qui est mélangé à
des ingrédients toxiques
ici c'est comme on donne aux membres du
club
deepak chaque pack il a dit g et on
donne 5 4 packs pour seul joueur ce pote
local sera vendu 2 dollars 50 le gramme
un cinquième du prix du marché noir
c'est comme ça que le gouvernement veut
couper l'herbe sous le pied des
narcotrafiquants ici dans le premier
clip de cannabis de montevideo
on trouve aussi une boutique
d'accessoires de type saas et
vaporisateur
il ya maintenant au pays une vingtaine
de boutiques comme celle ci le marché
est en pleine expansion
c'est la commission de transparence et
d'éthique publique indépendante qui doit
assurer le suivi scientifique de
l'expérience uruguayenne et évaluer les
dangers du cannabis et ya pa r rapport
scientifique qui nous assure
l'assistance de dépendance et n'a pas
non plus qu a connues d'intoxication
mortelle depuis l'entrée en vigueur de
la loi en décembre 2013
on a un premier bilan rassurant quant à
l'incidence sur la consommation
elle était en train d'augmenter depuis
l'an 2000
et la tendance se maintienne ne pas
différent donc qu'il n'y ait pas eu un
impact dans la première année sur la
construction est nécessaire
ce comité composé de médecins chimiste
sociologues et juristes est en contact
avec une centaine de chercheurs
internationaux incluant des canadiens
maintenant il ya la possibilité
désolé une réponse scientifique à tous
les questions pour c en ce qui concerne
l'usagé de la marijuana
par exemple la vente est interdite aux
mineurs est déconseillée aux femmes
enceintes
il y à aussi tolérance zéro pour tout le
monde au volant et sur les lieux de
travail comme pour l'alcool
et comme pour le tabac le cannabis est
interdite à l'intérieur des lieux
publics
toronto les drogues entre rosso
une campagne contre les drogues et
d'alcool est déjà en route
la reine nous allons intensifier les
mesures éducatives et préventives avec
cet avantage
nous avons maintenant un contact plus
direct avec les consommateurs
encore aujourd'hui la majorité des
uruguayens sont contre la loi à
commencer par ceux acquis gouvernement
va demander entre autres d'assurer la
distribution
les pharmaciens nous sommes contre parce
que nous sommes des centres de santé et
nous vendons des produits pour la santé
des produits qui font du bien aux gens
les pharmacies ont été choisies pour des
raisons de sécurité et elles devront
probablement se plier aux exigences de
l'état chaque consommateur devra
s'enregistrer pour acheter ses 40 g
mensuel mais il pourra le faire en tout
anonymat
seuls ses empreintes digitales
prouveront son identité
je suis étranger est ce que je peux
acheter de la marijuana
non non vous ne pouvez pas parce que
vous n'avez pas le droit de vous
enregistrer comme doit le faire un
patient ici sinon on aurait un tourisme
de la marijuana il n'y aura pas de
tourisme du pote en uruguay pas massif
en tout cas mais les yeux du monde
entier seront tournés vers l'expérience
tentée par ce petit pays alors qu'en
2016 et nations unies doivent revoir
entièrement leur approche face aux
drogues et au narcotrafic
nous essayons un nouveau chemin nous
sommes un petit pays qui communique bien
notre expérience pourrait servir au
reste de l'humanité l'aumône à un petit
pays où l'audace d'un président s'est
imposé à une société très conservatrice
où la consommation de cannabis n'est pas
encore vu d'un très bon oeil par tout le
monde parce que vous avez fumé la cité
du vent en seconde balle
ça ne se compare même pas nous
affirme-t-il